[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they actually talked to me about it
they thought it was funny hey there
happy friday my friday friends
so what is up with michael avenatti
don't worry i'm going to be fair to him
but the disgraced former porno scuzz
bucket dirtbag was sentenced to four
years in jail that's one year for every
follicle
the reason is stealing 300 grand from
porn star stripper the next mrs kilmeade
stormy
daniels i'm kidding
that relationship would never work well
with her book out selling kill me it's
three to one
but yeah avenatti stole 300 grand from
stormy wonder if it was all in ones
it's too easy we went to some lawyers
for comment
a hedgehog centipede
apparently part of his sentence will be
served concurrently
which means done at the same time cat
hopefully stormy gave him advice on how
to do that at the same time
they call that airtight
thank you kennedy
but that's how you know you're a sleaze
when you have to serve a sentence while
you're already serving a sentence
if you remember and i don't because i
snorted too much relief factor
avenatti is currently serving two and a
half years for trying to extort millions
of dollars from sportswear giant nike
when avenatti was heard complaining
about the sentence the judge told him
just do it
i feel really dirty
but it seems heartless stealing money
from a company like that it's just not
fair to the kids who work 16-hour days
in a windowless building in china
without a pee break so they could charge
hundreds of bucks for lebron's latest
shoe
but avenatti still has to serve 30
months of a new sentence after that we
went to stormy for her reaction
[Music]
it's funny because it's the bird
[Laughter]
according to the new york post assistant
u.s attorney matthew padalski told the
judge about how daniels felt about
avenatti's betrayal quote you can
imagine the incredible personal betrayal
that happened when she found out her
lawyer avenatti not only stole her money
but lied to her over and over again
yeah imagine being lied to over and over
again but if lying's a crime expect a
class action from every dude who thought
the stripper really liked him
stormy daniels isn't even her real name
she stole it from a local tv weatherman
in dallas
her real name is monsoon mcgillicuddy
it's terrible
during the sensing avenatti told the
judge i brought embarrassment and
ridicule upon myself and innocent third
parties including my family my children
my friends and the legal profession well
that quote is proof that he's still a
liar he doesn't have friends and it's
impossible to embarrass anybody in the
legal profession
as for stormy we hope she finds peace
it's yet another tragic case of a former
penthouse pet of the year
not realizing their dreams after a
promising start as a former penthouse
pet of the year
talk about unrealized expectations i'm
beginning to think posing new doesn't
help your career unless it's to pose
nude in the future or to be a host on
fox and friends
you know what i'm talking about ducey
that's why i've kept my clothes on most
of my career except during that time in
the mid 90s when i did those art films
i call them art films because art was
the only person who watched them
avanasi avenatti also said this to the
judge quote i've destroyed my career my
relationships and my reputation there is
serious doubt as to how or if i will
recover any semblance of a normal life
or peace
come on mikey you're selling yourself
short you'll be back like a raging case
of spring break cold sores
after all cnn rehired jeffrey toobin
they should give you a legal show with
him they could call it the ripoff and
the
and remember all the fans you made in
media i'm sure they'll be there too to
help you out i bet one of them will pick
you up on your release day i'm guessing
anna navarro on a bicycle built for two
maybe stelter will bring you a cake with
a file in it
minus the cake
because he probably ate it on the way
over
in the car alone
ah you know
just in this front seat cake spilling
all over the steering wheel
he's chomping at it then he licking the
file
looking at all the nooks and crannies
where am i the fleeting nature of love
you got lucky tonight we're back with
attorney michael avenatti he is a main
player to me you're like the holy
spirit all places at all times he's out
there saving the country look i think
you're doing a hell of a job i don't
think you're in this for money looking
at the 2020 one reason why i'm taking
you seriously as a contender is because
of your presence on cable news yes wow
man if i had a dollar for every time
stelter's been wrong i could buy him a
gym pass
or a bypass
but the point here is not to dance on
avenatti's misfortunes although it's
pretty fun and he'd likely do it to us
given the chance i'm just reminding
everyone how the media operates they'll
accept any vile creature into their
midst if the creature simply matches
their assumptions that's why harvey
weinstein was a predator for so long he
supported the right politics the media
embraced avenatti because he danced to
the tune they wanted to play it was all
but they dove head first into it with
bells on
but it's also hard to be sympathetic to
stormy daniels i mean if she was paid
130 grand in hush money to keep quiet
about an alleged affair she had with
trump why didn't she hush that's the
golden rule of sex work it's not just
for the sex but to shut up when you're
done
unless you talk dirty afterwards but
that really seems backward
i don't know why not
why did i nod
just nodded i knew the audience knew
better than to laugh at that one
i don't understand what he means
what's the point of talking personally i
don't care if trump slept with stormy in
fact as a billionaire from queens you're
required to sleep with strippers it says
so on the statue of liberty
so as the judge imposes a sentence in
avenatti remember that every day the
media imposes a sentence on you thanks
to places like abc cbs cnn msnbc you're
doing hard time enduring their phony
narratives shaped by miscreants starting
miscreants until finally it blows up and
they're over made up lying faces
avenatti took advantage of stormy but
the legacy media took advantage of you
thinking you were stupid enough to fall
for their stupid act avenatti's in jail
but the media rocks on when the only tv
screens they should be on are the ones
that monitor their cells
[Applause]
she's known for those trademark glasses
and then kicking asses host to kennedy
unbox business kennedy
he's the first of many to say thank god
i'm not joe devito
comedian and fantastic actor joe derosa
she's like an orange circus peanut
sobbed at first but crunchy after a
night out fox news contributor cat tim
and finally a pyramid is his paperweight
my massive sidekick in the new york
times best-selling author of the book
just tyrus which is now back in stock on
amazon the book company not the forest
iris
so before we get to the news i have to
talk about what's in front of me right
here which is a big stack of beautiful
sandwiches
look at that isn't this delicious so joe
i haven't seen you you always did red
eye then you became a big tv star
really why
okay i saw you on breaking bad better
call saul but thank you well you were
the same character there was my
character wasn't in breaking bad
thank you greg at least pretend like you
read up
before the show i missed
[Laughter]
so you open this up you opened a
sandwich shop and the loady side i
opened a bar and sandwich shop called
joey roses yeah on the lower east side
right during the pandemic very very
smart move yeah yeah yeah well the world
was crumbling and i panicked when you
wait
are these mainly subs
yeah the only food we serve are our
hoagies or subs whatever you want to
call them and then it's a full bar now
do people ever go in there and just take
pictures of you thinking you're jared
uh
i'm the good jared
we actually have a t-shirt coming out
that says our spokesperson isn't in
prison
it'll be available very soon
well i'm going to eat one of these but
i'll wait to the break so speaking of
prison um what do you make of this whole
avenatti thing i think i'm the only
person that is covering this because
everybody wanted to move on i yeah i i i
find him fascinating that he's stealing
book money he's such a numb nuts he
can't get his own book deal i mean i
don't understand what else this guy
needs to do he's he's a celebrity lawyer
he's tangled with the most infamous
president in history he represented
stormy daniels he's had a rise and fall
i don't know where his book deal is of
his own
but what's more fascinating to me is the
greed is a guy complicating his own life
you're already a lawyer number one
on top of that you're a celebrity lawyer
and that's still not enough
free money for him he's then got to
steal money yeah which would be like me
being lucky enough to open my own
sandwich shop which i did
and then you hear them stealing cull
cuts from subway
it makes an
excellent analogy but you know what it
was you know why kennedy he was living
beyond his means
that's what it is it always is that it's
like if you make a half a million then
you think you can spend a half a million
you know yes you're absolutely right and
then you know people like this he's such
a smarmy prick he just wants to flex
everything so we have to have the
lamborghini right yeah and the gucci
tracks dude and he's gotta have
everything so it requires a ponzi scheme
to support his lifestyle because you
know the half a million dollars he's not
gonna live comfortably in a thousand
oaks
he wants to live in west hollywood or
beverly hills and he's just a an
absolute super but having said that
still the most viable candidate that
democrats have in 2024
i want to see him by the way thousand
oaks
i counted it
it's not no
about 400 oaks 400 exactly solid 400.
that was a great afternoon tyrus wasn't
it we went around and counted trees
[Laughter]
why am i co-signing
i know it's friday but damn
do you think uh that anything will ever
cause a moment of self-reflection for
everybody in those clips or do they
prefer to just walk away from it no you
know what is surprising to me is i mean
why is stormy daniels not suing cnn why
is she not suing every one of those
supposed legitimate journalists that's a
good point who didn't do any background
checks on the guy that they were
anointing the most trustworthy honest
man he was quote a holy spirit or
something at one point he had made he
had made god status at least angel
status
and he's lying to you and you everything
you see on tv by these journalists is
that he's honest and forthright
why are you not suing cnn to get i mean
i'm not a lawyer you know what i'm
saying but i think i can make that
argument in court she can't thanks to
avenatti she can't afford another lawyer
i would think you'd pick it up because
then the last guy they lied about the
young man that they lied about
didn't they give him 125 million dollars
i don't know did they ever say what he
got i think they that was the low ball
remember he had bought a panda and sent
it to the moon he told him he couldn't
do it he was like
i'm not a scientist i'm just a guy with
a lot of money yeah i can't tell you how
much money i got but i just sent a panda
to the moon
because i can and that's not a euphemism
by the way
it actually is although it probably is
yes
cabo headed to the moon
where am i cat
i don't know
last word to you do you think he has a
comeback in his future it's only going
to be a couple years he'll be back he'll
have his he'll have another book deal
he'll have to pay his debts uh yeah i
mean it's just incredible to have a fall
this far
like he was they were talking about
having him run for president and now in
some states he can't even vote for the
president because of the felonies
and he was crying about you know how
hard his life is
and i don't doubt that
but that's because you got busted doing
felonies yeah like you're not supposed
to have an easy time that's why we make
them felonies like you're not supposed
to do these things so i don't think
he'll ever have a comeback not just
because of what he did but also because
he still sees this as being somehow not
fair right it's not fair that he's in
prison and not thinking about what he
did to other people he still has this
whole victim mindset of this is so
horrible that this happened to me it's
like you happened to you by the way he's
this is like
this isn't hard that hard time you know
what i mean he's going to be back he's
going to be like it's too bad there
isn't the new apprentice because he
would be on celebrity apprentice no he
would be if they brought if they brought
dr drew's celebrity rehab yes he could
maybe get in on that one and be voted
off in the first episode no offense to
dr drew but yeah a lot of people on
celebrity rehab never made it out
like that's just what i'm saying there's
some openings that show had a body count
how dare you besmirch the great doctor
no no one's been smurging and he tried
to help people who were like unhelpful
really sick i know even with with all of
that they still succumb to their illness
it's weird it's almost like drugs are
addictive
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else